-You did do "Fleabag"
one last time,
the stage show that it was
based on, in London.
Was that again, sort of,
for a piece of closure?
-Yeah. I mean, I had said
it was gonna be the last time
in New York.
-Yeah. And I saw it there.
And I paid through the nose
for tickets,
'cause I heard
it was the last --
-[ Laughs evilly ]
-Yeah, right. Exactly.
-That was the plan.
Yeah, and then we said
we weren't gonna do it again.
And then one of the most
beautiful theaters
in the London --
"In the London."
[ Laughter ]
In London's West End --
-Do you guys call it,
English people --
-We called it the London.
-Yeah. Okay, great.
-Just to be clear.
-That's a slang I didn't know.
-So you know which one it is.
And it's just such a beautiful
theater, and I loved it so much
that we sort of thought -- Oh,
it felt really good to go back,
'cause we started
at Edinburgh Fringe Festival.
And to end up in the West End
just felt like a really lovely
full circle.
But it was -- It was --
And it was the first time I'd
really felt the end so palpably.
I mean, I remember
on the last night,
and this sounds really cheesy,
and I don't normally go in
for this sort of stuff.
But -- But on the last night,
and I realized,
I've been playing this character
on and off for about six years,
and on the last night,
it was like the last four lines
of the play,
I actually felt her leave me.
-Wow.
-And I was like -- Yeah.
Vom, right? Vomit.
[ Laughter ]
But I really -- I really did.
I felt something happen.
I was like, "Oh,
I've got to let go now."
And then I was like --
She was like, "Bye-bye.
I'm going, you know,
to Australia now."
-Yeah.
-"Jump into another woman."
-She's doing a whole run
in Sydney. Yeah.
-Yeah, some other actress/writer
there just going, "Ugh!"
"What is that?"
[ Laughter ]
-I've heard that you travel on
public transportation in London,
and obviously, you're very --
You're popular there.
And -- People do
take videos of you. Yes?
-Yeah, that's the only weird --
Most of the time, people --
I mean, public transport
is kind of fine,
because no one's concentrating
on anything that's going
around them.
They're just, like, head-down
in their own personal hell.
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, it's
the secret filming of you,
when you're in your own
personal hell, as well,
it's like a little bit exposing.
But, so, that happens there.
So that's due a bit less there.
-Do you do anything --
It seems to me that there's
a unique opportunity for you,
if you're getting
secretly filmed,
to "Fleabag" a glance
right to camera.
I mean, that's the dream
for anybody who's filming you.
-I know, but the times
I've done it to those people,
they weren't
the people filming me.
They're just like --
[ Laughter ]
I'm, like, giving them
a little --
[ Laughter ]
And they're like, "No."
-"I am on Twitter."
Will you travel?
Will take advantage
of our beautiful subway system
while you're here
in New York City?
-I mean, I'll have a go.
I love the subway.
-Do you like the --
Is the subway better
than the Tube? Is it --
-Well, I think
it's just got that --
-The Tube is the subway
in the London.
[ Laughter ]
-We -- We, uh --
We in London have -- Well,
I mean, I have a relationship
with the Tube in London,
which is, you know,
we've been together
for a long time.
But I've seen its sort of grubby
edges, whereas here, it's --
I just know the subway
from movies.
And it's so cinematic.
And I love it,
and I'm sitting -- You know,
when I go on the subway,
I'm the person who's like,
"We're in the movie of our lives
in New York.
And this is amazing.
And there are, like,
beautiful rats.
And it's just, like, gorgeous.
I love it."
-Is it similar?
Are the rodents similar
in both public transportation
systems?
-No, we go more in for mice,
I think.
We're little mice
in little Edwardian jackets --
-Yeah.
-Playing little --
-Little tea.
-Playing us in and out
on their little violins.
-Oh, so when you get on,
they play a little song.
-[ Scatting ]
-[ Laughs ]
We actually have the only rats
in the world
that have middle fingers,
which is amazing.
-That's not true.
-No, it is.
They, like little -- I mean,
you have to like really look.
But they --
-Or really offend them.
-Yeah, you really -- And it's
like, they don't quite manage,
but, like, the rest of their
posture is very much like that.
So you're like, "Oh, I see
what you're trying to do here."
-They have to grow one.
-Yeah.
Over years, they're just --
It was like,
Darwin did a whole study
about how only here did rats
develop middle fingers.
-They had all the attitude
and nothing to do with it.
-Yeah.
-Now.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
It is always a delight.
Congratulations.
Oh, this is very exciting, too.
Taylor Swift is gonna be
your musical guest.
-Yes!
-And that is such
a nice combination of people.
And she came and saw your show
in New York or London?
-She did, in London.
-That's really cool.
-Yeah, yeah. It was amazing.
-She came backstage afterwards
and --
-Yeah, she did. We hung out.
Hung out with Tay-Tay.
-That's really great.
That's so amazing.
And Tay-Tay's a fan,
because she actually tweeted
when it was first announced.
She was the one --
She threw this out.
-That was amazing.
-And how exciting you are.
So, that's great.
-I know, she's so cool.
She's so lovely. It's so nice
of her to do that, as well.
-Cool points abound on Saturday.
And I can't wait to watch.
And thank you for being here.
And that is
Phoebe Waller-Bridge, everybody.